Russians spy satellite taking pictures
and God knows what get us up there
Harrison we can't justify a space
program that doesn't put anything in
space we all go end up unemployed riding
around in this pilot jump you welcome to
all the 16 miles go sit in the back of
the bus we're putting a human in the
space we bring him in too soon he burns
up on reentry
I need math that doesn't yet exist find
a mathematician before the Russians
plant a flag on the Daniel you have
identification I had no idea what a few
women working in the space program test
booth needs a computer yeah there was a
gal for that she can handle winning
numbers you put in boom never had a
color in here but don't embarrass me
this was an empty last night I'm a negro
woman I'm not gonna entertain the
impossible I'm standing beneath a
spaceship we are living thinking
possible the IBM data processing system
we have know how to program it did it
that's John Glenn what do you ladies do
for NASA calculate your trajectory so
you can get anywhere without the numbers
how could you be up in these white men
it's equal rights I have the right to
see that in Africa
NASA doesn't commission females for the
engineer program every time we have a
chance to get ahead
I would like to attend today's briefing
there's no protocol for women attending
they move the finish line it all should
be thankful you have jobs it up
I don't even know if I can keep up in
that room you're better with the numbers
than anyone in that capital you've been
on for 300 hours don't like it too me
too
women everywhere I need you to be where
the hell do you go every day the kulluk
bathroom is a mile away we all get to
the peak together we don't get there at
all often 50 million people are watching
this long John the IBM's wrong let's get
the girls to check the nose nails
already we can do the work come clean
let's get to know NASA hasn't given up
on good old-fashioned brainpower
the friendship seven has experienced
some sort of a malfunction there's a
little fireball outside still a little
hot in here the fight of our lives
people friendship seven do you copy over
Katherine we all go end up unemployed
riding around in this pilot jumping
you're welcome to up the 16-month I'll
sit in the back of the bus